[Music]
so quick background on pleat psmith we
automate device setup intelligence
patching and security for your company's
Apple devices one of the coolest things
we do is make it so that factory fresh
laptops and iPhones and iPads can be
dropped drop shipped directly to remote
employees without prior manual setup by
IT and as soon as they're unboxed and
connect to Wi-Fi they automatically
enroll all the option settings are
installed automatically over the
Internet securely we built our product
on GCP in part due to Google's high bar
for security and we actually roll our
own kubernetes cluster on top of GCE and
use hash core vault for secrets
management PKI
and crypto as a service if we were
actually going to deploy kubernetes
today we would use gke where we're only
rolling around cluster for some legacy
reasons awesome so this talk assumes
that you have some knowledge of
containers and kubernetes and focuses on
practically protecting your workloads in
gke specifically we're gonna dive into
what's your responsibility versus what
Google handles for you I will say also
just in general security in the cloud is
that shared responsibility between your
cloud provider and you Google does a lot
of things to protect the underlying
infrastructure like encryption at rest
by default and also providing
capabilities to you that you can use to
protect your workloads like I am as
newer infrastructure models emerge it's
not always easy to figure out what
you're actually on the hook for so
that's really what we're diving into on
this talk so let's jump in and review
some kubernetes basics from a security
point of view to make sure that we're
all on the same page so within that
kubernetes cluster there's only really
three core fundamental pieces these are
the parts of the diagram that you see in
dark grey and let's walk through them
from the bottom up so at the bottom
layer you've got the storage that's at
CD think of this like the kubernetes
hard drive next up you've got the master
that controls your entire cluster and
then the next layer up you've got the
nodes that's the machines virtual
machines that are running
pods and pods are just collections of
one or more containers so let's now walk
through the damage that can be done at
each layer from the top down so at the
top layer you've got the containers
again in the pod if an attacker can
control a container they can do things
like abuse compute to do things like
mine cryptocurrency for example schedule
arbitrary workloads on the node if
they're able to escape the container
potentially access customer data and
yeah if there's if there isn't a strong
security boundary there they could
potentially escape to the node from the
node if an attacker control can control
a node that means they can control all
the pods running on a node they can do
things like abuse compute at the node
layer kill existing workloads and run
arbitrary workloads they also may try to
attack the master the next layer up and
do things like you know denial of
service attacks for example so next up
you've got the master itself that
controls your entire cluster controls
workloads where they're scheduled
everything so if an attacker compromises
your master that's pretty bad they can
compete completely take your environment
offline and short of killing the entire
you know cluster there's really not much
you're going to be able to do to be able
to react to that type of attack
finally Etsy d again like your
kubernetes hard drive right that stores
the entire cluster state so it's kind of
like stealing a harddrive right they're
gonna get all your configs the attacker
could create modifier or destroy your
entire cluster and they may even be able
to recreate or model your entire cluster
elsewhere so let's look at Google's
shared responsibility model and how that
applies to Google Cloud so you might
have heard this term shared
responsibility model before it refers to
how in the cloud the cloud provider and
the user split the responsibility to
protect your what you what you're
running so to be successful at this your
cloud provider it has to be really clear
about which aspects of security they're
responsible for and which aspects and
security you're responsible for
generally providers are responsible for
securing infrastructure and you're
responsible for securing workloads let's
break this down for Google Club so as
you can see in the diagram here Google
cloud manages the blue bits whereas the
user manages the Green
infrastructure-as-a-service on the left
users are responsible for things like
network security the deployment itself
and web app security whereas Google is
responsible for cathode just the core
infrastructure for platform-as-a-service
in the middle Google takes on more of
the responsibilities including
components like authentication identity
and operating the service the user is
still responsible for deploying and
securing their application and on the
right for software as a service Google
is also responsible for these pieces and
so you as the user only responsible for
protecting your data and content using
the appropriate access policies this
break down is actually available on a
white paper that we published late last
year on Incident Response and I'll link
to that at the end of the talk but
looking at this where it is BKE fall
right it's probably closest to the
middle that is Google manages a lot of
the day-to-day running of a service but
you're still responsible for your
specific workloads that run on gk so
let's quickly recap what actually
happens at that bottom layer first the
blue that goes across all of the bottom
and how Google protects those services
on Google Club so one of the key
security differentiators for google
cloud is our core infrastructure right
the infrastructure doesn't rely on any
single technology to make it secure
rather we build security from a
progressive layers that deliver
defense-in-depth so starting from the
bottom up with hardware Google purpose
builds hardware in our data centers from
chip to network in order to ensure a
secure supply chain service deployment
we have a build test and deployment
pipeline that ensures that code running
on our servers and our data centers is
meant to be there so that any
application binary that runs the
infrastructure is purposely deployed
this lets us enforce requirements that
like ensuring that code is reviewed by a
second reviewer and in other such
policies and requirements we might have
once deployed we don't assume any trust
between services they actually need to
authenticate to each other in the
environment so we were built we built
this in fresh infrastructure to be
multi-tenant from the get-go at the
storage layer data stored and
infrastructure is automatically
encrypted at rest and distributed for
available a team rather reliability we
also moment strict data access controls
and robust logging features at the
storage layer underlying several of the
applications that you can use on Google
Cloud
Adeiny in access all identities users
and services are strongly authenticated
this authentication for users for
example using hardware second factor
helps protect against phishing attacks
secure communication communications over
the Internet to our cloud services are
encrypted and communications between
services internally are authenticated
and encrypted when they go between
physical boundaries and operational and
device security the scale of our
infrastructure allows us to absorb a lot
of attacks including DDoS attacks and
our ops team works 24/7 to respond to
threats and incidents all of this is
explained in detail in another way paper
called our infrastructure security
design my paper that I'll also link to
at the end of the talk but just note
that the way that Google does a lot of
these things is unique write anything
that runs on top of this stack including
Google's workloads but also Google Cloud
workloads that our users want to run
benefit from having these underlying
protections so go into gke beyond that
base infrastructure let's look at
kubernetes if you're running kubernetes
yourself for example on GCE on-prem
whatever it happens to be you're
responsible for managing all of it
including the control plane and
day-to-day operational work we often see
users start with their own deployment
and then when it becomes too much to
handle migrate over to GK if instead of
used gke
kubernetes engine is a lot of the heavy
lifting for you so for kubernetes engine
at a high level the items on the left
google is responsible for protecting in
addition to the underlying
infrastructure that I mentioned already
the kubernetes distribution so a Koopa
dainese engine makes available the
latest upstream version of kubernetes
supporting several minor versions
providing updates to these is Google's
responsibility in the control plane in
crew Bernays engine Google manages the
control plane which includes a master
VMs the API server and other components
running on those VMs and the NCD
database this includes upgrades again
including patching scaling and repairs
all backed by an SLO the operating
systems that your nodes run such as
container optimized OS or costs and new
boon to kubernetes engine promptly makes
any patches to these images available
note that this is the system running on
your no it's not not the OS running
inside your containers right think about
container
to OSS what do you think about this
Google cloud and as in the last piece
that Google manages for you our Google
cloud integrations for I am called audit
logging cloud security command center
cloud kms staff driver etc these enable
controls available for for is workloads
across Google cloud directly in GK
conversely the user is responsible for
protecting the pieces on the right the
nodes that run your workloads including
VM images and your configurations you're
responsible for any extra software
installed in the nodes or any
configurations changes made to the
defaults you're also responsible for
keeping your nodes updated Google
provides hardened VM images and
configurations by default manages the
containers that are necessary to run gke
and provides patches for your OS you're
just responsible for upgrading if you
use node auto upgrade and move that
responsibility of upgrading the nodes
back to Google and you're responsible
for your workloads including your
application code docker files container
images content and your running
containers and pods this includes
leveraging gke features and other GCP
features to help protect what your
weight you're running in containers so
let's go and through the couple of bit
components here the control plane the
worker nodes and then your workloads to
see how we would protect each piece so
the control plane first Google I just
mentioned Google is responsible for
securing the control plane which is the
component of kubernetes that manages how
kubernetes communicates with the cluster
and applies the users desired state to
the cluster this is Google's
responsibility what does that mean well
if you look at how gke is architected in
gke the hosted control plane components
run in a Google owned GCP project and
they control resources that are in a
user's GCP project each customers
control plane components run on GCE
instances and these instances are single
tenants meaning that each instance runs
the control plane and its components for
only one customer so what's actually in
that control plane a couple of different
pieces first the master VM it's a set of
virtual machines that runs master
components like I just mentioned these
are single tenants GCE VMs in a Google
owned project
Google uses container optimized OS or
costs for these and manages the health
of these VMs including updating the OS
the API server
scheduler controller manager and other
controllers run on top of these master
VMs these are the typical functions of
your communities cluster after all the
API that you're interacting with when
use gke is the same as a normal you know
criminals api that you get by running it
yourself it just happens to be managed
by Google the control plan also manages
xcd which is a database behind
kubernetes which maintains state just
like the rest of GCP contents stored in
at CD and gke is encrypted at the
filesystem layer by default so you don't
have to do anything to get that at CD
only listens on to TCP ports 1 to
communicate with the kubernetes api and
the other four server-to-server
communication when transmitting traffic
from one end CD server to another these
communications are protected using
mutual TLS next piece the control plan
also runs the cluster CA and manages the
clusters root of trust key material each
cluster has its own root certificate
authority the API server and cubelets
rely on kubernetes cluster root CA for
trust each cluster runs its own CA so
that if one cluster CA would be
compromised no other cluster CA would be
affected an internal Google service
manages root keys for the CA and these
are privately held by Google outside of
the cluster I am authentication and
authorization is handled by the master
as well this works the same way for the
criminales api server and at CD as it's
done for other Google cloud services and
lastly the master includes the audit
logging configuration for the master
components this provides a detailed
record available in stackdriver of calls
that are made to the Carbonite ease API
server that was quite a lot so the goal
here and throughout kubernetes engine as
you'll see is to give you strong
security everywhere control where you
need it
insane defaults in case you never quite
get around to configuring that thing
yourself
so keeping the goal of sane defaults in
mind we've been making hardening changes
to the control plane over time so let's
see what's actually changed recently
let's look at the changes in some of the
recent gke releases first in 1.7 the
kubernetes dashboard and gke had its
highly privileged admin access
removed you might have heard of a couple
of public hacks of kerbin Eddie's in
which case you've probably seen the
dashboard prominently featured Tesla
Aviva Weight Watchers were all affected
in late 2017 and early 2018 where they
had their dashboards deployed on the
public web not password protected and
had privileged cloud service account
credentials in their attacker has found
the dashboards one and took the
credentials logged into to the cloud
service and started cryptocurrency
mining so on gke we had actually made
this hardening change before these
attacks occurred in 1.8 gke enabled
role-based access control or are back by
default in the v1 API our back is a
method of restricting access to
resources based on roles and permissions
in kubernetes its implemented to allow
you control access to pods deployments
config maps jobs basically anything you
can think of it's meant to replace it
replaces the prior authentication method
of attribute based access control and
provides a more intuitive way of
handling permissions by using our back
you can more easily follow the principle
of least privilege to set roles with
minimum permissions to resources inside
your cluster in 1.83 GK enabled cloud
audit logging with the default current
IDs policy so that both your GCP API and
the kubernetes api audit logs are
written to stack driver for admit
activities does lets you easily go back
and see who did what and when in your
cluster in 1.10 in response to the
attacks that I mentioned earlier that
were happening in the wild against Tesla
and other I just lost my mic ok good in
response to the attack which occurred in
the wild against Tesla and others we
disabled the coronaries dashboard by
default and gke instead you can use the
cloud console to have this the same
functionality the monitor clusters the
next bit requires a little bit of
explanation
so criminales offers several
authentication methods in gke the
supported methods are open ID connect
tokens x.509 client certificates and
static passwords gke manage manages
authentication for G cloud by using the
Open ID connect token method setting up
the community configuration for you
getting an access to
and keeping it up-to-date the other
authentication methods x.509 certain
static passwords prevent present a wider
surface of attack so basic auth has
never really been a best practice and
x.509 certain kerbin nes are poor are
poorly auditable so unless your
application specifically needs these you
shouldn't be enabling these in your
cluster so starting in 1.12 gke no
longer generates these credentials for
you by default when you create a new
cluster and also ng in 1.12 gke removed
access to the GCE legacy and metadata
server api's for your cluster some
practical attacks that were happening in
the wild against kubernetes rely on
access to the VMS metadata server to
extract the nodes credentials notably
Shopify last year had a bug bounty where
a researcher accessed this metadata and
had broader access to the cluster than
expected so we removed that by default
note that all of these hardening efforts
that I've been talking about change the
defaults for new clusters right we can't
do this for older clusters to allow for
backwards compatibility so if you have
an older cluster that you've been
continually upgrading please go in and
make sure to change some these defaults
yourselves to get the the leading edge
security so critically though Google is
also responsible for patching anything
running in the control plane we have a
high bar for security and but you know
bugs do occur in in open source projects
and things that we you that are running
in your clusters so we want to make sure
to promptly patch these Google
automatically upgrades the master VMs
but you're responsible for upgrading our
notes and I'll talk more about auto node
auto operate in a second so looking at
you know there's since there are so many
different pieces here let's quickly let
this go over what this looks like in
practice it depends where the
vulnerability is if the vulnerability is
in the kernel or an operating system
Google will apply the patch to affected
components including obtaining and
applying the patch to host images for
kubernetes costs and open to Spector in
meltdown and L 1tf are examples of such
vulnerabilities if the vulnerabilities
in kubernetes well Google's involved in
free Benes product security team and
often helps develop and test patches for
kubernetes vulnerabilities since gke is
an official distribution google receives
the patch as part of the private
distributors list
if the vol is in a component used in GK
use default configuration for example
calicos contain a network interface CNI
or a net CD then in this case Google may
receive a pact from upstream kubernetes
from a partner or from the distributor
list of another open-source project
and lastly if the vuln is in gke itself
for example if it's discovered through
vulnerability rewards program then
google is responsible for developing and
applying the fix in all of these cases
Google makes the patches available as
part of general kubernetes engine
releases which are the patch releases
and bug fixes as soon as possible given
the level of risk embargo time and any
other contextual factors where the
vulnerability is severe enough or user
action is required we publish a Security
Bulletin detailing this information on
our website so that was the control
plane now look at the notes the worker
notes for your notes Google does most of
the hard work by providing the
components that you need and the patches
that you need for those when there's a
security issue but it's still your
responsibility to upgrade in order to
reap those benefits in kubernetes your
worker nodes are where you run your
workloads your worker nodes in gke
consists of a few different surfaces
that need to be protected including the
node OS the container runtime kubernetes
components like the cubelet and queue
proxy and google system containers for
monitoring and logging google provides
all of these components and where
necessary you decide what you want for
your notes so you get to choose the
operating system between costs and a
blue two and you choose a runtime that
you'd like separate containers run for
critized components like queue proxy and
cube dns and Google specific add-ons to
provide logging monitoring and other
services Google's responsible for those
containers in all of these cases Google
is responsible for patching these
components but you're responsible for
deciding when to upgrade to apply those
patches so for example a patch to cost
to container D or kubernetes would all
be provided by gke but the user has to
upgrade to apply them
let's talk a little bit more about the
OS choice gku provides two options for
your node OS again this is the OS
running on your node not the OS running
inside of your container you can use
container optimized OS or cots and
Ubuntu as mentioned earlier GK's control
plane uses costs you're deciding what
you want to run on your worker nodes so
why should you consider costs well it
has a couple of nice security properties
cost is based off of chromium OS Google
maintains all of these components is
able to rebuild from source if a new
vulnerability is discovered and needs to
be patched often allowing us to make a
patch available sooner than if using a
third party distribution cost is minimal
and has a smaller attack surface qasas
purpose-built to run containers and so
has a smaller footprint than other os's
this means less code less complexity and
therefore less patching right there's
less stuff to patch if you never had the
component in the first place cost is
hardened with good security defaults I
really want to emphasize this this is
very critical for some of the recent
vulnerabilities we've had like run C
these were prevented but preventable
because of cost of security properties a
firewall restricts all TCP UDP traffic
except SSH on port 22 and load pin
prevents kernel modules from being
installed a read-only root filesystem
and verified boot makes persistence for
attackers more difficult cos also allows
security features like set comm to
further constrain your application to
its normal behavior and EB PF for third
party security products to monitor
lastly cost offers automatic updates so
in gke we provide cost updates on a
weekly basis as part of a normal release
process your nodes will automatically
download the updates in the background
and then upgrade when you reboot so
we've been talking about notes and how
your primary responsibility for these
nodes to protect them is to update them
right to make sure you benefit from the
hard work that Google does to patch the
pieces running on your nodes what if
even that you could just hand over to
Google and that's exactly what no dotto
upgrade is it's funny we I think we
talked a lot about no-doubter upgrade as
being a reliability feature but I
entirely think about it as being a
security feature right node upgrades
help keep your nodes up to date with the
latest stable version of kubernetes
this means you stay up to date with
feature changes but it also means that
Google can apply the security patch to
your notes when it's critical note auto
upgrade is available for costs and also
more recently for Ubuntu so you have no
reason not to turn it on so I mentioned
that note Auto keeps you in the latest
stable patch how does this work
if there's like a newly disclosed
security vulnerability well a patch with
the vulnerability fix is rolled into the
first possible release after public
disclosure often this this is a patch
that's released the day of a disclosure
but then takes multiple days to actually
roll out and be available everywhere
then several weeks later once a release
is considered stable it's applied to the
whole fleet for some security patches
where it's particularly critical this is
actually done much sooner so why would
you not turn on auto-grade well you
might need deeper validation of an
update yourself or want additional
control and predictability for your SRE
team to be on call if this is the case
consider turning on auto upgrade with a
maintenance window so that you'll only
apply it will only apply it during that
time period we also see users turn off
node or upgrade around major launches or
events like Black Friday where changes
are particularly sensitive to their
environment note auto upgrade works by
creating a new node and moving the
workload over to that node let me
quickly explain how surge auto upgrade
works which are newer developments to
note auto upgrade first we create a new
surge VM and once it's up and running
create the node on that VM that takes a
few minutes once the new node is ready
the old node is drained of the workload
and once it's fully drained the workload
resumes on the new node training the old
node takes a few seconds and with the
workload up and running on the new node
we can now delete the old VM so we heard
in the keynote this morning talk about
live migration right this is applying
the same concept for your workloads for
your nodes running in your environment
live migration also underlies all of gke
so you get that automatically anyways
and because of the security benefits and
ease of maintenance we're slowly moving
to making auto upgrade the default for
new clusters in gke so four clusters
created in the UI since about October
auto upgrade is checked by default four
clusters created with G cloud starting
for G cloud beta in 113
you
longer have to pass the enable auto
upgrade flag if you don't want to if you
if you don't sorry if you to enable this
if you don't want to use this you can
pass the - - no enable auto upgrade flag
and it's not yet the default in the API
though so be careful if you're an opt-in
if you're primarily using the API in all
of these cases though you can still opt
out by unchecking a box or passing a
flight great let's talk about workload
security so what we've been talking
about so far is the underlying
infrastructure that runs your workloads
but of course you still have to worry
about the workloads themselves and
application security and other aspects
of your workloads protecting that is
your responsibility not googles so when
we talk about hardening your workloads
there's really two places you need to
look to secure them your kubernetes
configs that pertain to your workloads
and obviously the workloads themselves
so last year my and I presented a
roadmap for securing your organization
on kubernetes as amateurs some of the
things are handled automatically by gke
and some aren't last year specifically
in terms of kubernetes configs we talked
about a few of these things not all of
them things like using a network policy
using namespaces and setting a pod
security policy and one that we didn't
go into in detail last year is
protecting secrets so we'll talk a
little bit more about that today in
terms of additional controls you can put
in place for your application you can
verify binaries scan images for known
vulnerabilities and you sandboxing to
learn more about all of this stuff check
out that talk from last year it's called
kubernetes for enterprise security
requirements and for an up-to-date list
of best practices we recommend checking
out the hardening or cluster security
guide this year we wanted to focus on a
few of those areas we didn't get to dive
into last year like I mentioned such as
protecting secrets so what is a secret a
secret can be a lot of different things
technically it's any sensitive data that
your application needs either at build
time or a run time some common examples
are TLS private keys API keys username
and password combinations to access your
database for example
or external services like your payment's
processors such as a stripe API key
things that are not considered secrets
are your code and general configuration
files so let's say you're using nginx as
your web server the nginx config file is
not a secret but the private key the TLS
private key that's referenced by that
config is a secret it's also worth
calling out that there is sensitive data
or personally identifiable information
and PII
these things are not considered
quote-unquote secrets even though
they're obviously sensitive data and you
still want to protect that sensitive
data or PII but generally you want to do
that by encrypting it before it's you
know written to the database for example
and you wouldn't typically store that
type of sensitive data directly inside
your secrets management system so by
default in kubernetes secrets are stored
in that storage layer a net CD but they
have no additional protection they're
protected in the same way as the rest of
that CD so a pod can access secrets via
the filesystem either as an environment
variable or via an API call and
effectively all nodes can access all
secrets and users with access to add CD
can XML trade secrets in plain text
starting in kubernetes 1.7 kubernetes
offers application layer encryption for
differential protection of secrets using
this feature your secrets are encrypted
with a key that's specified in the local
@ CD secret config but this option is
actually not recommended because it
doesn't actually improve your security
if you think about your threat model
it's actually the same exact threat
model as it was before
since the critical data that an attacker
would access is being stored on the same
place as the key so it doesn't really
help you starting in kubernetes 1.10
kubernetes offers something called
envelope encryption of secrets using a
kms provider we're not going to go into
a lot of detail here about a quick
summary of how it works is that there
are two keys and then the data that's
actually being encrypted so in this case
the data being encrypted obviously is
the kubernetes secrets that are stored
with a net CD key number one is called
the key encryption key or kek the only
purpose of that key is to encrypt the
and key the second key is called the
data encryption key and as you could
probably guess it's only purpose is to
encrypt the data for more details on how
all this stuff works check out the talk
by Seth Vargo and Alex Janikowski called
securing kubernetes secrets it's worth
pointing out that on Google cloud we've
used this functionality that's from from
kubernetes natively into gke so we
support this with a feature called
application layer secrets encryption for
gke which is in beta you can use a keen
cloud KMS to encrypt the data encryption
key that encrypts your secrets in gke
it addresses the encryption requirements
that a lot of users have for those
secrets and provides that separation of
duties between who manages the secrets
and your clusters and who manages keys
so at policemen we currently use hashing
Corp volt for secrets management this is
because we currently run a hybrid
environment what I call a hybrid
environment where some of our
application runs and VMs and some runs
in containers so because of that we rely
on something called the GCP
authentication plugin for hash a core
vault to bootstrap secrets onto new
instances if you're also running that
kind of hybrid hello okay so if you're
also running a hybrid type of cloud
infrastructure where you have both
instances or VMs as well as kubernetes
pods or collections of containers then
vault is actually a great solution for
that you do have that that challenge
though of how do you you know safely
bootstrap those secrets onto new
instances and pods and that's where
things really get tricky so make sure
you're safely bootstrapping those
secrets you want to use the GCP off
method for your VMs with vault and you
want to use the kubernetes off method to
bootstrap secrets onto your pods with
kubernetes and of course regardless you
want to be really careful with your ACLs
to make sure that you're scoping the
access to your secrets to only the pods
or only the VMS that actually need
access to those secrets right I will
actually say though if you're starting
fresh today and you don't have you know
kind of legacy reasons for rolling your
own kubernetes cluster I highly
recommend just going with gke and using
encrypted secrets if you want to learn
more
on that topic check out the talked
keyless entry securely accessing GCP
services from kubernetes that talk is
tomorrow Wednesday April 10th from 2:00
10:00 to 3:00 p.m. awesome so other ways
we can help with your workload security
you know Google offers a few products
and features to make this easier first
manage based images and disrelish images
so I was talking earlier a lot about the
node image the node OS this is about
what's running inside your container
right you're gonna have a base image
that you build your container on top of
and you build that into an application
image and that's actually what you
deploy so your your container may just
take it by is built by taking that that
operating system base images and adding
the the the libraries the packages the
binaries that you actually need manage
base images is our one option and these
are images that are patched for security
vulnerabilities automatically by Google
with the most recently available patches
from upstream Google maintains several
base images for building its own
applications including things like App
Engine and so manage base images
actually have a couple of nice security
properties as well then make them a
desirable choice for your applications
specifically there regularly scanned for
known vulnerabilities from the CVE
database the scanning is done using the
same functionality as container registry
vulnerability scanning if you've seen
that before and we're patched for these
exists it's applied they're built
reproducibly so that there is a
verifiable path from source code to the
binary that means that the image can be
verified to ensure that no flaws have
been introduced by comparing it to
source and lastly they're stored on
google cloud so you can pull them
directly from your environment without
having to traverse networks you can pull
these images using private Google access
managed base images are available for
Debian Ubuntu and CentOS another option
an alternative to menace base images are
destroy less images these images only
contain your application and its runtime
dependencies greatly reducing the
potential surface of attack write a
package with a newly discovered
vulnerability can't affect you if you
don't actually have the package in the
first place right this is how you become
more secure less stuff dis for those
images remove package managers shells or
other programs that you might find in a
standard Linux distribution so that
you're focusing on what's actually
important which is you know
dealing with the the vulnerability
scanner results that you have and
leaving it was less to maintain this
rule is images are a language focused
and available for many languages
including Java Python node.js net and
more as well as a static image for
statically compiled languages like go
rest in D both distress images and
manage base images are good choices for
your containers it really depends on
what works in your environment if you
need a full Linux distribution including
features like a package manager or a
shell then manage base images are a good
choice if you want the most lockdown
option possible then distres distress
images might be better for you so now
that you've have a base image and you've
actually built your container image you
have a something that you're storing in
your in your image registry that you're
going to deploy so for those application
images you'll also want to avoid
including any known vulnerabilities and
those to assess that in Google container
registry you can use vulnerability
scanning GCR vulnerability scanning when
enabled scans all the images in your
private registry for known CVEs from the
CVE database this is displayed in your
registry with info as to whether a fix
is available and the severity of the
vulnerability etc so that you can
actually take action this scan is
conducted on a new image when it's added
to the registry as well as when new for
existing images when a new vulnerability
is discovered and added to the database
GCR vulnerability scanning is available
for Debian Ubuntu CentOS and Alpine
images and at the end of the day if
you're responding to something happening
in your environment you can look up at
called security scanner sorry that made
no sense you can also use cloud security
scanner to scan for common web
application vulnerabilities unlike for
other services security scanner sorry
like for other services security scanner
can be used on public facing
applications hosted on gke it scans for
cross-site scripting mixed content
outdated libraries clear text passwords
and other common like OS top ten like
bones so now we've protected our
infrastructure right the control plane
the worker nodes and your workloads
themselves and unfortunately insecurity
bad things still happen
so what do you do what do you when you
have to respond to a security incident
now it's also worth noting I'm making a
difference here between incidents and
vulnerabilities right a new
vulnerability if it's not currently
being exploited in your environment is
not an incident you should have that
handle by your normal vulnerability
assessment response team so responding
to attacks on Google's infrastructure is
Google's responsibility
whereas responding to attacks on user
workloads is the users responsibility
basically we're each responsible for
responding to attacks pieces that we
protect that makes sense so how do you
handle Incident Response so before we
answer that question you know what we
have to define what does that actually
mean being responsible for you know
incident response on your workloads well
it really means to start you need to
understand the incident response
lifecycle and so let's just quickly go
over those stages that means being able
to identify when an incident actually
occurs establishing a runbook for what
happens once an incident is declared
staffing your own response team who will
actually be following that runbook in
the case of an incident understanding
the scope of the incident by conducting
forensics and finally notifying any
affected users if that's applicable and
developing and executing on a
remediation plan so if you're responding
to an incident and you're on Google
cloud there's a few tools that you can
leverage with gke to Kentucky to help
conduct your own incident response first
up is absolutely critical you need to
make sure you have a centralized log
aggregation system set up on Google
cloud stack driver could help with this
it comes prepackaged with common queries
that are helpful for addressing
incidents specifically that occur on gke
so for example in the case of a cluster
compromised you might want to quickly
check what resources were asked accessed
by the attacker and you can leverage
those types of built-in queries instead
of spending valuable minutes on writing
those queries from scratch yourself and
next stackdriver
Incident Response and management is a
new product from Google that's an alpha
it's a set of new tooling that they're
specifically developing to help you
reduce time to mitigation in an incident
response scenario on Google Cloud
if you're interested in more material on
incident response including how Google
themselves uses a really awesome
open-source tool called ger internally I
highly recommend a talk from last year's
Google cloud next called cloud forensics
101 and if you're a start-up that's just
getting started with incident response
there's a really great starting point in
the form of a blog post by someone named
Brian McKeon it's titled an incident
response plan for startups and you can
find the link at the end of this talk
finally I do want to call out Brian's
not a Googler
he's formerly a director of Incident
Response of Facebook as well as director
of security at corn base and he
currently has his own consulting firm
called r10 and security so if you are
responding to an incident GCP then you
probably want it's a cloud security
command center of first cloud security
command center is the single pane of
glass for security events in your
environment for scans that you run in
your environment you can see the results
that apply via GK clusters here as
you're looking to further protect
yourself from potential container
specific attacks Google cloud already
has a range of container security
partners integrated with cloud CSEC
these look for attacks against your
container workloads and then alert you
directly natively in CSEC these include
aqua security capsule 8 stock rocks
Cystic secure and twist lock and we're
always looking at Anwar to our partner
offering so we've talked a lot about a
you know a handful of security features
that you can leverage in Google Chrome
earnings engine and Google cloud this
actually lots more gke also offers
features like private clusters and pod
security policy to help you protect your
workloads another one that I didn't talk
about I just want to quickly emphasize
is binary authorization which is
inspired by what Google does internally
to verify code before it's deployed so
you can actually use that to enforce
what gets the put into your environment
based on an attestation so for example
to enforce that code must come out of
your build pipeline or that it must be
scanned by your vulnerability scanner
using these pieces together it leads to
a stronger security posture because
after all strong security is really
about defense-in-depth
so putting it all together you know
let's answer that initial question of
who protect
what in gke google is responsible for
protecting the control plane which
includes your master vm @ çd and
controllers and you're responsible for
protecting your worker notes including
deploying patches to the OS runtime in
kubernetes components and of course
securing your own workload so what could
you do today to start securing Cabernets
on gke we'd recommend that you stay at
the forefront of security by using node
auto upgrade protecting your workload
from common image and application
vulnerabilities using managed base
images or destroy those images and GCR
valen scanning and following the Korean
engine hardening guide to get on the
latest set of configurations that we'd
recommend and then you have a bit more
time check out some of the additional
content that we covered in additional
documents we link to so here's a set of
links to learn more the first one is a
blog post that covers the content of
today's talk there's a landing page on
container security a link to an overview
on security the hardening guide and the
security Bolton's that's what I
mentioned earlier when there's a new
vulnerability disclosed that's where we
post information has an RSS feed you can
use that to you know post directly to
your team / channel for example and then
the last two points there are incident
response white paper and our
infrastructure security design white
paper and if you're next the rest of
this week check out some of the other
talks on container security going on so
we're in the upper left here but there's
a talk later today on secrets and on
networking and then tomorrow on securely
accessing GCP services from kubernetes
Thursday on software supply chain policy
management and G wiser that's it for us
thank you so much for your time
[Music]